the film is called the king of staten
island it's directed by judd apatow man
that's uh
that's a pretty big deal to get him to
direct the film yeah i feel really lucky
getting judd when you get jud it's like
getting like
dr dre to like produce your album it was
uh
it was really big for me i really
appreciated it how'd it come about but
he call you up
yeah we met uh we met on the set a train
wreck and uh we became
friendly and then over the next couple
years we just tossed around ideas here
and there and then finally we landed on
the story we really wanted to
dive into my childhood and dig deep and
try and get this story made
but it was his idea to you know what if
what if pete's
mom started dating a fireman was was his
idea and then
the ball just started rolling after that
yeah you got your mom in there marisa
tomate and then bill berg who's a real
funny guy
but the movie is you know based on your
life
growing up without a dad especially if
your dad dies tragically
as yours did most people know that your
father died at 9 11.
and i think the message is if you lose
your father in a tragedy you are going
to be
[ __ ] up from it your theory is all of
your problems
stem from that right the trauma of your
dad dying
yeah i think uh i think most of those
problems i just you just carry on into
your adult life and uh
my goal was to try and you know move
past
that and that ain't an easy topic to
tackle in a movie
i was like wow you know but the movie's
funny we did a junket the other day and
it was just people from like germany
being like
so pete your dad is dead
your dad is dead and he's never coming
back how's film
and i'm doing man yeah